the former guerrilla fighter is due to
be officially sworn in on sunday he's
promising to reshape the deeply
polarized country with a long list of
reforms and social programmes alessandra
piety has more from bogota
long time social leader elvira patino
can hardly contain our excitement for
the star of gustavo petros government
it's like returning to life the
possibility of change not only for me
but for my entire community that needs
it so much it fills me with high hopes
herself a victim of paramilitary
violence she has volunteered during the
campaign convincing dozens of other
victims to end their apathy towards
politics
we went home to home and they would say
they had no confidence in politicians
but i showed them the government's plan
and how this was the opportunity to
finally get education health jobs and
this gave them hope and they voted for
petrol
petrol sky-high ambitious program
promises to fight inequality for
colombians like elvira through a raft of
reforms starting with taxing the rich to
fund social programs
but many in the country are nervous
gustavo petro will have to play a
complicated balancing act on the one
hand he will have to show that he can
quickly deliver some relief to his
constituency while at the same time
acting with enough caution to appease
his detractors who see him with deep
unease
many who work in financial markets fear
his plans to ban new oil developments
could damage the economy and the
country's military which petra is
promising to transform
but incoming president has managed to
build a broad congressional coalition
and appointed moderate internationally
recognized officials to key economic
posts
still observers say none of it will be
easy
we've been trying to pass these reforms
for many years now there's a real
opportunity but it's a very complicated
moment there are very little resources
available the outgoing government left
nothing due to the pandemic and there's
an international economic crisis
senator gustavo bolivar one of petro's
closest allies says their supporters
will need to be patient
when you generate so much expectation it
is very easy to fall we need to teach
people that we can't do things quickly
especially in a country with so many
issues like colombia
there is a crisis at all levels deficits
at all levels but we must show the
country in the first hundred days that
change is on the way and one way will be
to fully implement the 2016 peace deal
and start negotiations with remaining
criminal groups
already made history winning the
election the question now is if he will
be able to translate that victory in
transforming the government of a country
longing for change alessandra
al jazeera bogota